GOOD MORNING THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW
IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF CALDERON
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
THANK YOU ACOSTA.
AGUIAR CURRY.
ALLEN.
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE.
CABALLERO
CALDERON
CARILLO.
SIR BONTA AS
CHAU.
CHAVEZ
CHEN DAVID CHIU. CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM.
SALLY EIGHT MEN
FLORA. FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRAYSON
HARPER.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA%
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS.
MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MASUCCI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO STEINORTH
STONE.
THURMOND
TEEN VOEPEL.
WALDRON. WEBER. WOOD.
YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
TODAY'S PRAYER.
THE DAYS A VOCATION WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND BOB LISTA. RIVER NOTES
TO.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IT IS GOOD TO BE REMINDED. THAT
VALENTINE'S DAY WILL BE HERE IN
TWO DAYS.
IT WAS IN THE MIDDLE AGES OF
EUROPE DURING THE TIME OF
CHAUCER. IT VALENTINE'S DE
BECAME ASSOCIATED WITH ROMANTIC
LOVE.
THE IDEALIZED GOAL IS THAT
ROMANTIC LOVE WILL LEAD TO A
LIFETIME UNION.
IN DISCUSSING THE TOPIC OF
ROMANTIC LOVE WITH MY WIFE
PATTY.
SHE RECALLED THE SIXTY ONE YEAR
ROMANCE OF OUR UNCLE AND AUNT.
TO OCEAN BEACH GOLF COULDA WHO
LIVED IN BERKELEY.
WE WERE MARRIED ON DECEMBER
EIGHTH NINETEEN FORTY SIX AND
ENJOYED A TRULY ENVIABLE
MARRIAGE.
IN DECEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY
SIX WE CELEBRATED THEIR GOLDEN
ANNIVERSARY.
THAT EVENING I ASKED UNCLE TO
OCEAN AND TO MEET YOU. WHAT THEY
FELT WAS THE SECRET TO THEIR
MARRIAGE?
A MARRIAGE WHERE THEY ALWAYS
TREATED ONE ANOTHER WITH SUCH
GENTLE RESPECT AND KINDNESS.
AUNTIE WAS A BIT EMBARRASSED BY
MY QUESTION. BUT UNCLE THOUGHT
FORM IN A MINUTE AND THEN SAID.
MY MOTHER WOULD TELL ME THAT IN
CHOOSING THAT SPECIAL PERSON TO
MARRY.
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE BOTH EYES
OPEN.
THEN SHE ADDED.
AFTER YOU'RE MARRIED CLOSE ONE
EYE.
I IMMEDIATELY LOOKED AT PADDY
AND SAID PATTY CLOSE ONE EYE.
WITHOUT HESITATION SHE SAID WITH
YOU BOB I HAVE TO CLOSE BOTH
EYES.
WE LEFT.
WE LEFT BUT THIS SOUND ADVICE
OUR OWN COULD POST RECEIVED FROM
HIS MOTHER. OVER SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO. WE PASS ON TODAY AS
OUR VALENTINE'S GIFT TO ALL OF
YOU.
NOW MORE ON THEM.
WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS.
I INVITE YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
FOR TODAY'S FLAG SALUTE WHAT WE
WHAT WILL BE LED. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO.
READY BEGAN.
DURATION. PRODUCT.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT.
I NATION.
DIGITAL. PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
CLERK WILL READ THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY JANUARY THIRTIETH TWENTY
EIGHTEEN
ASSEMBLY MET AT SEVEN A. M. ON
BILL ROCKY JAY CHAVEZ ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEVENTY SIX DISTRICT
RECITER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISTER GLORIA SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
MOVING TO OF MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROCKY
SCHABAS FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN.
WE HAVE A LEAVE OF ABSENCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND FOR MEDICAL ISSUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADAM GRAY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MULLIN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN NAY TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SPOTS A
CUNNINGHAM
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND MATHIS
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON
THE FLOOR TODAY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS GAS WILL BE SEATED AT HIS
DESK WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AND AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM TWELVE SJ ARE THIRTEEN
SKINNER TO THE ENACT.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA. FROM
MISTER MULLINS DESK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTION.
I'D LIKE IT'S YOU ON INTERVIEWS
MY ONE AND ONLY DAUGHTER I KNOW
WE MENTIONED OF THE OTHER DAY
THAT SHE.
GIVE HER BROTHER'S A HARD TIME.
THIS IS MARGARET MARINE MATHIS
SHE WAS ACTUALLY BORN ABOUT NINE
HOURS BEFORE I TOOK MY ORIGINAL
OATH OF THIS OFFICE.
.
PERMISSION TO USE OR PROP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MAGAZINE YOU
SAY HI.
IT'S A HIGH.
ALRIGHT. THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE MEMBERS THE
ASSEMBLY I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
CURRENT AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
WERE PRESIDENT CONJUNCTION WITH
CALIFORNIA NEW YOUTH CONNECTIONS
THIRTIETH ANNIVERSARY. WITH
THOSE YOUTH PLEASE PLEASE RISE
SO WE CAN RECOGNIZE YOU AND
WELCOME YOU
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS
INTRODUCTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I
AM PROUD TO WELCOME A VERY
SPECIAL GROUP OF STUDENTS FROM
CAL POLY SAN LUIS OBISPO.
ALONG WITH COWBOY PRESIDENT JEFF
ARMSTRONG.
TO THE STUDENTS I'D LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ARE HERE WITH US ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITH THIS WE HAVE JEREMIAH
HERNANDEZ WHO WAS AWARDED THE
CSU TRUSTEES AWARD AND SCOUR
SHIP FOR HIS SUPERIOR ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE.
ALSO HERE IS ALI HOW ROCKY WHO
WAS AWARDED THE PAST PRESIDENTS
TROPHY FOR THE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY NINTH TOURNAMENT OF ROSES
PARADE.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE TO THESE.
VERY ACCOMPLISHED STUDENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MISTER MULLIN
STATUS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS THE PROUD.
REPRESENTATIVE OF THEIR HOME IN
WEST OAKLAND IT'S MY PLEASURE.
TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THE
CALIFORNIA DIVISION ONE FIVE
DOUBLE EIGHT ACCLIMATIZED WILL
CHAMPIONSHIP FOOTBALL TEAM.
AND THEY'RE HERE.
IN THE GALLERY AND THE SIDE BY
SIDE WITH ME. MCCLINE ENDS
LOAN WE'LL SEE I HAVE TO.
LAST YEAR YOU MAY RECALL.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME ANOTHER
HERE WITH US AGAIN
AFTER WINNING FOR A SECOND YEAR
IN A ROW IN.
IF THEIR SUCCESSES LAST YEAR ONE
ENOUGH THEY BUILT ON THEM THIS
YEAR THEY HAD AN UNDEFEATED
SEASON. THEY PREVAILED OVER
THEIR OPPONENTS BY AN AVERAGE OF
THIRTY TWO POINT SO IT'S THAT
WHILE WITH A VERY NICE IT WAS
VERY IMPRESSIVE.
AND UP WITH US TODAY OF ASSEMBLY
FLOOR.
WE HAVE THE CLIMATE SAID COACH
MICHAEL PETERS
AND OAKLAND ATHLETIC LEAGUE
SUPERVISOR HAROLD PETE PEARSON.
ALONG WITH SENIOR TEAM CAPTAINS
ALBERT MITCHELL AND CHARLES
ALBERTINE. AND IN THE GALLERY OF
THE REST OF THE CLAIMANTS
CHAMPIONSHIP. FOOTBALL PLAYERS I
HAD THE PLEASURE OF JOINING THEM
FOR THE CELEBRATION RALLY IN
JANUARY IN OAKLAND ON THEIR
THEIR CAMPUS AND NOW IT IS MY
HONOR TO RECOGNIZE THEM ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. CONGRATULATIONS
TO THE WARRIORS IN REQUIREMENTS
HIGH SCHOOL OF THE CITY OF
OAKLAND AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE VERY PROUD OF
YOU.
WE HAVE A RESOLUTION THAT
HONORED YOUR ACHIEVEMENTS AND
YOUR GREAT WORK LET'S ALL GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS
ACHIEVEMENTS
MEMBERS WE WILL BE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
TODAY'S BUSINESS.
THE CLERK WILL READ ITEM ONE A.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO WATER TO
CLAIM THEIR AND SEE THEIR UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES AS AS YOU
KNOW WELL ONE YEAR AGO TODAY.
I ALONG WITH TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF MY CONSTITUENTS WERE
EVACUATED. AS A RESULT OF THE
SPILLWAY FAILURES AT ORVILLE
DAN.
WE LEFT.
NOT KNOWING IF WE WOULD EVEN
HAVE A HOME TO RETURN TO.
BUT WE CAME BACK VOWING NEVER
AGAIN.
THIS DISASTER JEOPARDIZE LIVES
PROPERTY.
AND CALIFORNIA'S WATER SUPPLY
AND CONVEYANCE SYSTEM. AND
SHOULD BE A WAKE UP CALL. FOR US
ALL.
THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY. AND INTEGRITY
OF OUR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE GOVERNOR TOOK SOME GOOD
INITIAL STEPS LAST YEAR AND.
IN THE RESOURCES TRAILER BILL
BY UPDATING OUR WRISTS
CLASSIFICATION SYSTEM.
AND DOING A COMPLETE
RECONNAISSANCE OF OUR DAM
SPILLWAYS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
TO SUPPLEMENT THE STEPS AB
TWELVE SEVENTY.
CO AUTHORED BY SENATOR NIELSEN.
AND ALSO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
STOCKTON.
I HELPS TO ADDRESS DEFICIENCIES
IN OUR DAM SAFETY INSPECTIONS
AND EVALUATIONS.
MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
OUR WORK IS NOT DONE BY PASSING
THIS BILL TODAY BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
INCLUDING CHANGING THE DAM
SAFETY STRUCTURE.
AND CULTURE.
ADD THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
IMPROVING AND UPGRADING.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AT ORVILLE
DAM.
AND MAKING THIS FACILITY TRULY
WORK FOR OROVILLE. AND THE
COMMUNITIES DOWNSTREAM.
THE FORENSIC REPORT WHICH MANY
OF YOU HAVE SEEN. IDENTIFIED THE
ROOT CAUSES OF THE FAILURE.
AND THAT REPORT.
IDENTIFIED THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN
MISSING.
IN LIGHT OF THIS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED IN THE REPORT.
INCLUDING INSPECTIONS.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY WILL CODIFY.
THE DAM SAFETY INSPECTION
SCHEDULE. PRIOR TO THIS.
THIS THOSE STATUTES SAID DAMN
SHALL BE INSPECTED FROM TIME TO
TIME.
I'M SURE YOU CAN ALL AGREE WITH
ME THAT WAS NOT SUFFICIENT
LANGUAGE THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH AN
INDEPENDENT DAM SAFETY AND RISK
MANAGEMENT ORGANIZATION. TO
UPDATE DAM SAFETY PROTOCOLS.
THESE PROTOCOLS MUST INCLUDE
THINGS IDENTIFIED BY THE
FORENSIC REPORT LIKE REVIEW OF
THE ORIGINAL DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION.
I THINK ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS ISSUE
AND MANY OTHERS RELATING TO THE
OROVILLE DAM CRISIS AND I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. OF AB TWELVE
SEVENTY THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT IS A CO AUTHOR
OF AB TWELVE SEVENTY.
WE'VE HAD TO OVERSIGHT HEARINGS
WE'VE BEEN UP TO THE DAM
MULTIPLE TIMES TO REALLY TRY TO
DECONSTRUCT WHAT HAPPENED UP
THERE. EVERYBODY CAN AGREE THAT
IS THE THE LYNCH PIN OF OUR
CALIFORNIA WATER SUPPLY.
TO HAVE SOMETHING THAT
CATASTROPHIC OCCUR SHOULD BE A
WAKE UP CALL FOR ALL OF US.
AND TO CERTAINLY WHAT WE'VE
HEARD IN THE HEARINGS AND
EVERYWHERE ELSE IS THAT WHILE
PEOPLE WERE DOING INSPECTIONS IT
WAS DONE BASED ON ACCEPTING THE
SCIENCE FROM SINCE THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. AS WE KNOW OUR
KNOWLEDGE AS AS EVOLVED AS WE
KNOW OUR INFRASTRUCTURE ALL OF
IT IS CRUMBLING AND NEED IS IN
THE NEED OF A LOT OF UPDATE. AND
WE ALSO THE NEED TO LOOK BACK AT
THE PLANS ARE NOT JUST CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT WHAT IS THERE NOW BUT
LOOK UNDERNEATH.
THEY THOUGHT THAT DAM WAS
ATTACHED A BEDROCK IT WAS NOT
THAT WAS THE INITIAL PLANS SO TO
BE ABLE TO GO BACK LATER.
MEMBERS ALSO BE WHERE THIS ALL
GOING TO COST.
EXPEDITION RESOURCES AND TIME
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR THE
SAFETY OF CALIFORNIA WE CANNOT
BE THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CONTINUES TO
CRUMBLE AROUND US. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND AS MY.
COLLEAGUE FROM NICHOLAS SAYS
THIS WILL BE THE LAST TIME WE'LL
BE TALKING ABOUT HOW WE CONTINUE
AND TO PROVE OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND KEEP CALIFORNIA SAFE AND
FUNCTIONING.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER GALLAGHER DO YOU
FEEL THE NEED TO CLOSE.
OKAY WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING THE VOTES SIXTY
EIGHT.
I KNOW ZERO ON THE URGENCY SIXTY
EIGHT I KNOW ZERO ON THEM
MEASURE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEMS TWO THROUGH SIX WILL BE
PASS AND RETAIN.
THE CLERK WILL READ ITEM SEVEN
ACR ONE FIFTY FIVE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY FIVE BY SOME AMBER
BAKER BELT OF ABRAHAM LINCOLN'S
BIRTHDAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FIFTY
FIVE AND TO SAY IT IS A GREAT
HONOR TO PRESENT THIS
RESOLUTION.
RECOGNIZING TODAY AS ABRAHAM
LINCOLN DAY.
EVERY MAKING WAS BORN THIS DAY
IN EIGHTEEN OH NINE IN KENTUCKY.
AND.
I HAVE SOMETIMES WERE ASK
THIS QUESTIONS FROM SCHOOL
CHILDREN ARE FROM OTHERS WHO SAY
IF YOU WERE TO SPEND TIME IN
HISTORY. OR TIME WITH ANYONE IN
HISTORY MAYBE THREE PEOPLE WHO
WOULD THAT BE A MY LIST AS LONG
AS I'M SURE YEARS MAYBE AS WELL
BUT ABRAHAM LINCOLN IS ALWAYS ON
THAT LIST.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS WHY IS
NOT ALL BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT PATTY HAD HONOR
HISTORY BUT I THINK YOU'LL BE SO
FASCINATING TO HAVE KNOWN.
WITHOUT PRESIDENT'S PERSONALITY
WAS TRULY LIKE WHAT HIS DEMEANOR
WAS HIS ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE
ONE ON ONE IN PERSON WHICH WE
WE.
HAVEN'T AND WILL NEVER HAVE A
CHANCE TO EXPERIENCE.
AND TO SEE HOW MUCH WE MAY HAVE
EXAGGERATED HIS GREATNESS IN
TERMS OF HOW NICE A PERSON HE
WAS HOW GIVING AND WHAT A GREAT
COMMUNICATOR.
BUT ONE THING YOU CAN NOT
EXAGGERATE IS THE IMPACT HE HAD
ON THE CAUSE OF LIBERTY.
AND FREEDOM NOT JUST IN UNITED
STATES BUT AROUND THE WORLD.
AND WE SAW THAT THROUGH ONE OF
HIS GREAT TRAITS WHICH IS
COMPLETE AND TOTAL ABSTINENCE
AND DETERMINATION TO KEEP OUR
UNION TOGETHER.
WE HAD EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO CUT
AND RUN AND SAY WE'RE DONE.
SO MUCH FOR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IN THE
GETTYSBURG ADDRESS.
RE ASK THE QUESTION IS A COUNTRY
THAT'S CONCEIVED IN LIBERTY.
THE PROPOSITION THAT ALL MEN ARE
CREATED EQUAL EQUAL ABLE TO
ENSURE OR ARE WE DONE IN
HISTORY.
ARE WE ABLE TO HAVE A COUNTRY
LIKE THAT OR DO WE NEED TO
REVERT BACK TO THE WAY IT USED
TO BE CAN WE SEE HIM IN PROGRESS
IN FREEDOM.
AND.
HE WAS.
ABLE TO EXPRESS THAT THAT
MISSION OF OUR COUNTRY THE NEED
TO COMPLETELY FULFILL.
THE PROMISE AND THE TRUTH OF THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE AND
THANKFULLY HE DID THAT BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE PERSON IN THIS ROOM
IS HERE FOR MANY PEOPLE HAVE AN
INFLUENCE ON YOU BUT I THINK
ALSO BECAUSE ABRAHAM LINCOLN DID
THAT. AND PRESERVED OUR UNION.
AND ALSO OF COURSE HE WAS
COMPLETELY OBSTINATE IN FIGHTING
TO END SLAVERY AND PASSED THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT.
HE HAD MANY OPPORTUNITIES IN
HISTORY TO HAVE PEACE WITH THE
SOUTH WITHOUT PASSING THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT TO ABOLISH
SLAVERY AND ALL FORMS OF
INVOLUNTARY SERVITUDE.
HE COULD HAVE AGAIN CUT AND RUN.
HE COULD HAVE SAID NO THAT'S NOT
IMPORTANT I JUST WANNA KEEP THE
UNION TOGETHER BUT HE WAS
DETERMINED TO END SLAVERY. SO
MUCH SO THAT HE HAD AN AMENDMENT
TO THE CONSTITUTION WHEN HE WAS
VERY MUCH OPPOSED TO AMENDMENTS
HE THOUGHT THE CONSTITUTION IS
FINE THE WAY IT WAS.
AND EVEN SCIENCE THE ORIGINAL
AND GROSSED COPY OF THE
THIRTEENTH AMENDMENT PERSONALLY
EVEN THOUGH THAT'S NOT REQUIRED.
AND SO THEY FULLY HE WAS
OBSTINATE AND DETERMINED IN
KEEPING OUR UNION TOGETHER AND
FIGHTING TO END SLAVERY.
.
I THINK YOU CAN SEE IT IN ONE
QUOTE THAT IS PARTICULARLY
FAMOUS FOR WHICH IS BE SURE YOU
PUT YOUR FEET IN THE RIGHT
PLACE.
AND STAND FIRM.
DON'T GIVE UP.
BUT WHAT'S ALSO INTERESTING
ABOUT LINCOLN I THINK.
IS THAT HE WAS JUST AS COMMITTED
TO RECONCILIATION. AND HEALING
AND GRACE AFTER YOU HAD FOUGHT
THAT BATTLE FIRMLY KEPT YOUR
FEET FIRM AND DEFEATED SOMEONE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IN THE
SECOND INAUGURAL ADDRESS.
WHERE HE ACTUALLY SAYS WITH
MALICE TOWARDS NINE AND CHARITY
TOWARDS ALL WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF THE CONFEDERATE WIDOW?
WHOSE WHOSE HUSBAND OR WHO
SIGNED FOUGHT TO KILL UNION
SOLDIERS.
AND THAT IS EXTRAORDINARY GRACE
AND LEADERSHIP.
AND THIS WASN'T JUST SOMETHING
THAT HE. WAS SUGGESTING WE DO.
WHEN.
WHERE PERSONALLY SLIGHTED WHICH
OFTEN HAPPENS IN POLITICS
AND IT WASN'T JUST SOMETHING
THAT WAS A A PRIVATE?
OPPORTUNITY TO RECONCILE AND
HAVE GRACE TOWARD SOMEONE ELSE
HE WAS ON THE WORLD STAGE IN IN
HIS SECOND INAUGURAL SUGGESTED
THAT WE FORGIVE AND MOVE ON.
REALLY REALLY HARD TO DO YOU.
AND THANKFULLY HE DID BECAUSE
AGAIN I THINK WE ARE ALL HERE
THANKS TO ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
AND I I BRING THIS RESOLUTION
AGAIN THIS YEAR JUST AS I HAVE
IN THE PAST WITH A REQUEST FOR
PERMISSION TO USE A PROP WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
MY FATHER GOT ME THIS REPLICA OF
LINCOLN AT THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL.
WHEN I GRADUATED LAW SCHOOL.
HE REALLY WAS HOPING THAT IT
WOULDN'T BE A LAWYER BUT SO MUCH
FOR THAT.
AND SOMETHING IT'S URBAN LEGEND
I THINK IT'S TRUE THERE'S A
REASON WHY LINCOLN HAS A FAST
CLOSED AT THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL
AND THAT IS THAT DETERMINATION
TO FIND YOUR PLACE IN THE RIGHT
AND STAND. TOTALLY FIRM BUT HIS
OTHER HAND IS OPEN.
TOWARDS RECONCILIATION.
REACHING OUT AND MOVING FORWARD
AND SO I AM THANKFUL.
TO BE HERE AND HAVE THE HONOR TO
HAVE THIS RESOLUTION FOR US TO
VOTE ON VERY GRATEFUL FOR
LINCOLN AND THE THE LEGACY HAS
NOT ONLY ON THE UNITED STATES
BUT THE WORLD AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. AND YOU ASK
FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION.
IN THE MIDST OF A BETTER CIVIL
WAR.
RECONCILE ALL IN THE PEACE.
NEVER WAVERED.
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR HE RAN ON
A UNITY TICKET WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
FROM TENNESSEE.
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS I'VE
SEEN THIS WORK ON VARIOUS PIECES
OF LEGISLATION.
SUCH AS JAMES GALLAGHER'S
THAT WE HAD THIS MORNING.
AND THE WORK ACROSS PARTY LINES.
THAT IS SOMETHING LIKE AND
STRIVE FOR AS PRESIDENT.
TO FIND AREAS OF COMMON INTEREST
AND WORK TOGETHER TO ACHIEVE IT.
PERMISSION TO READ BATUM SPEAKER
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IN THE SECOND INAUGURAL ADDRESS
LINCOLN SAID.
WITH MALICE TOWARD DAWN.
WITH CHARITY FOR ALL.
WITH FIRMNESS IN THE RIGHT AS
GOD GIVES US TO SEE THE RIGHT.
WHETHER STRIVE ON TO FINISH THE
WORK WE ARE IN.
TO BIND UP THE NATION'S WOUNDS
TO CARE FOR HIM WHO SHALL HAVE
BORNE THE BATTLE. FOR HIS WIDOW
AND HIS ORPHAN.
TO DO ALL WHICH MAY ACHIEVE AND
CHERISH.
I JUST AND LASTING PEACE AMONG
OURSELVES AND WITH ALL NATIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON ACR ONE FIFTY FIVE.
I THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEEN SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
FOR THE DAY FOR SENIORS RISING.
.
I ALSO RISE ON BEHALF OF ACR AND
ONE FIFTY FIVE IN JUST A UP A
PERSONAL REFLECTION WITH WITH
NOTHING TO READ BUT. BUT WORDS
JUST THAT THAT STRIKE ME AS I
THINK ABOUT LINCOLN.
AS ELECTED OFFICIALS WE ARE
FACED IN SOME INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
IF WE'RE LUCKY BECAUSE FACING
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS. ALLOWS YOU
THE ABILITY TO KNOW THAT YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE A VERY HARD AND
DIFFICULT CHOICE ABOUT
SOMETHING.
A REFLECT WHEN I WAS ON THE
STUCK CITY COUNCIL AND WE WERE.
.
CAREENING INTO BANKRUPTCY.
AND WE HAD HOURS AND HOURS AND
HOURS AND. DAYS AND WEEKS AND
MONTHS OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND.
A LOT A LOT HAVE JUST DIED VERY
INTENSE DEBATE CRITICISM.
YOU NAME IT WE HAD IT I WAS I
WAS HUNG IN EFFIGY OUTSIDE A
CITY HALL WHAT'S.
AND A TIME TO THINK DO I JUST DO
THE EASY THING.
FOR SOME PEOPLE WERE VERY VOCAL.
OR I DO THE HARD THING BECAUSE I
KNOW WHAT'S THE GOOD OF THE
WHOLE.
AND IT'S HARD TO STAND IN THAT
PLACE AND IT'S HARD TO LOOK
YOURSELF IN THE MIRROR EVERY DAY
AND SAY MY DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
DURING THAT TIME I HAVE ENOUGH
TO GET TRIP BACK TO DC TO SPEAK
AT A CONFERENCE HOSTED AN
ACADEMIC THAN. A AND I WENT TO
HIS SUMMER HOME WHICH IS RIGHT
OUTSIDE OF DC. AND I WAS STRUCK
WITH THE STORIES THAT THAT
SUMMER HOME A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE
OF TOWN IS WHERE THE WOUNDED
SOLDIERS.
CAMPED OUT.
VIDEO TO RIDE SIX MILES INTO
TOWN EVERY DAY IN A WAGON AND GO
BY CAMPS AND HOSPITALS OF
SOLDIERS AND PEOPLE DYING. LEGS
BLOWN OFF ALL AROUND HIM AS HE
JUST KEPT GOING. PEOPLE CALLING
UPON HIM TO STOP AND KNOWING
THAT IT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO FOR THE GREATER GOOD. YOU
INCREDIBLE HARD THINGS THAT WE
FACE SOMETIMES AS IT LOOKED AT
OFFICIALS AND SO I THINK IT
WOULD TAKE ANYTHING FROM MY FROM
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
JUST TAKE A SOMETIMES THE
GREATER GOOD IS SO HARD TO GET
THROUGH. AND THE INSTANT
GRATIFICATION FOR US TO STEP
AWAY AND TO TURN OUR HEADS IS SO
COMPELLING BUT IF WE HOLD THAT
LINE.
HEARD ON THE NEWS TODAY THAT MY
OF MY CITY WENT FROM BEING A AND
THE FIRST BANKRUPTCY THE MOST
MIDDLE PET PLACE AMERICA THE
MOST VIOLENT CITY IN AMERICA TO
THE SECOND MOST PHYSICAL.
FISCALLY HEALTHY CITY IN THE US
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH A
TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN
FROM.
AT THE SOUTH SIDE NOW AS
LEADING US AS MAYOR SO IT WE
PROVE PERSEVERE AS DID LINCOLN
AND SHOWING US A PAST THAT EVEN
IF IT'S HARD.
THERE'S SOMETHING ON THE OTHER
SIDE I THINK WE ALL DO BETTER TO
SERVE IN HIS IMAGE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ACR ONE FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM PLEASED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF HR ONE FIFTY FIVE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
RAMON FOR BEING HERE FOR
BRINGING.
THE BUS TO THE.
MODEL THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL HERE.
YOU KNOW LINCOLN'S.
LIFE IS VERY IMPORTANT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE PLACED IN THE
UNION.
AND JUST FOR A QUICK THINGS IN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE SYMBOLISM
OF.
OF HIS LIFE HOW CONNECTS WITH
US.
THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL THERE BELOW
THE HANDS
HAS THE SAME SYMBOL WHAT IS THE
MOST PERVASIVE SYMBOL IN AND
AROUND OUR CAPITAL. THE BUNDLE
OF STICKS
CASH NINE OF EVERY LAMP IN THE
PARK.
ON THE STAIRCASES THE MONUMENTAL
WEST STAIRCASE THE SOUTH
STAIRCASE IT UNDER HERS TO
RAILINGS.
IT'S IN THE SECOND FOUR DOORS
WHICH REALLY ORIGINAL SENATE
DOORS IN OUR CAPITAL FOR CEILING
PICKING UP CAPITOL MALL YOU SEE
THAT SAME. BUNDLE OF STICKS YOU
SEE RIGHT THERE NAME HAVE LINKS
WILL MORAL.
THE BILL ITSELF REMINDS US OF
UNION.
IF WE ARE COMING FROM THE
INDUSTRY SIDE YOU SEE THE WEST
PORTICO.
WHICH IS A PORTRAYAL OF UNION.
THAT VITAL THING THAT ABRAHAM
LINCOLN SOUGHT TO PRESERVE.
THAT IS THE EAGLE.
ABOVE A SHIELD REPRESENT
AMERICAN UNION.
AND TWO FIGURES CLASPING THEIR
HANDS.
IT IS A SYMBOL OF UNION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA IS A PART OF
THE UNION.
WHEN WE ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE
THE STREET LOOKING FROM CHICORY.
WE NOW SEE THAT SAME SHIELD IT'S
NOW OBSCURED BECAUSE WHAT IS.
A PARENT NOW IS THIS IS THE
GREAT SEAL OF CALIFORNIA.
BEING ADDED TO THE UNION SHIELD.
AND IT DOMINATED THE UNION
BECAUSE OF THE GOLD WEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA EIGHTEEN FIFTY.
WE CONTINUED DOMINATE THE UNION.
BUT. SO IN THIS BUILDING ITSELF
WE REMEMBER THE WORK OF LINCOLN.
PRESERVING THE UNION.
THE OPEN ARMS TO OTHER STATES TO
BE A PART OF THE UNION
AND CALIFORNIA'S SINGULAR ROLE
WITHIN THE UNION.
ALL CELEBRATED. ON THE SOUTH
PORTICO THE NORTH PORTICO.
AND.
OF COURSE IN OUR OWN CHAMBERS
SO ITS GREAT HONORED. TO THINK
OF HIM ON THIS.
.
HIS BIRTHDAY AS I WAS REMINDED
DISPLAY.
THANK YOU. SEEN A PRO THE
DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I JUST WISH TO TANK ARE GOOD
COLLEAGUES HAVE FOR THEIR
ELOQUENT. OF SUPPORT OF THE
RESOLUTION.
BE SURE YOU PUT YOUR FEET IN THE
RIGHT PLACE AND STAND FIRM.
AND WHEN YOU DO ALSO REMEMBER
THE RECONCILIATION THAT EVEN
LINCOLN WAS ABLE TO SHOW TO HEAL
OUR NATION AND MOVE FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE FIRST ROLE FOR.
MEMBERS THIS RULES BURKE CO
AUTHORS ONLY.
ALL MEMBERS WISHING TO COAUTHOR.
PLEASE INDICATE.
THE CLERK WILL PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLL THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL DO A VOICE VOTE ON THIS.
RESOLUTION ON FAVOR PLEASE SAY
AYE.
THE MOTION PASSES.
RESOLUTION PASSES.
I MADE WILL BE PASS AND RETAIN
MOVING TO ITEM NINE ACR.
SIXTEEN.
I ONE SIXTY SIX.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
BAKER RELATIVE TO INTERNATIONAL
DAY OF WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
SCIENCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FEELING UNUSUALLY
TALKATIVE TODAY THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER.
I LIKE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE SIXTY SIX AND ON BEHALF OF
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRESENT THIS AND ALSO AS A MOM
OF A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD GIRL WHO
LOVES MATH AND THANKFULLY IS
MUCH BETTER AT IT THAN I AM.
I IT IS TO RECOGNIZE A WOMEN AND
GIRLS IN SCIENCE THE IDEA FOR OR
AN INTERNATIONAL DAY OF WOMEN
AND GIRLS AND SCIENCE WAS
CREATED ON FEBRUARY ELEVENTH.
JUSTIN TWENTY FIFTEEN DURING THE
FIRST WORLD WOMEN'S HEALTH AND
DEVELOPMENT FORUM. WHICH WAS
ORGANIZED BY THE ROYAL ACADEMY
OF SCIENCE OR NATIONAL TRUST AND
UNITED NATIONS DEPARTMENT OF
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL AFFAIRS.
THE GOAL OF THIS DAY IS TO
EMPHASIZE THE NEED FOR EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY AND REPRESENTATION
OF GENDERS IN STEM FIELDS. AND
WHILE IN RECENT YEARS A NUMBER
OF WOMEN INVOLVED IN SCIENTIFIC
FIELDS HAS INCREASED WOMEN STILL
ONLY ACCOUNT FOR LESS THAN
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE WORLD'S
RESEARCHERS. AND EVEN LOWER
PERCENTAGE AT HIGHER DECISION
MAKING LEVELS IN SCIENCE.
AND WHILE RIVER RECEIVE OVER
HALF OF BACHELOR DEGREES AWARDED
IN BIOLOGICAL SCIENCES THEY
RECEIVE FAR FEWER IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE ENGINEERING PHYSICAL
SCIENCES AND MATHEMATICS.
SO THE NEED FOR GENDER EQUALITY
IN STEM FIELDS IS NOT ONLY A
MATTER OF FAIRNESS.
BUT IT'S A MATTER OF LOST
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN FOR GIRLS
AND SOCIETY AS A WHOLE WHEN THEY
MISS OUT ON CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
WOMEN CAN MAKE IN OUR SCIENCE
FIELDS.
I AM SO THE ACR CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE THAT BUT IT'S ALSO TO
REMIND US.
OF JUST HOW MUCH WOMEN HAVE
ROCKED IN SCIENCE.
MARY CURRY WAS THE FIRST WOMAN
TO WIN THE NOBEL PRIZE FOR HER
GROUNDBREAKING RESEARCH IN RADIO
ACTIVITY.
ROSALIND FRANKLIN WAS A CHEMIST
AND EXTRA CRYSTALLOGRAPHY HER
BEST KNOWN FOR HER CRUCIAL
CONTRIBUTION TO THE DISCOVERY OF
THE DOUBLE HELIX STRUCTURE OF
DNA AS WELL AS PIONEERING THE
USE OF XRAY DIFFRACTIVE
FRACTION.
AND LISE MEITNER WAS A PHYSICIST
WHO IS ONE OF THE FIRST
SCIENTISTS TO DISCOVER NUCLEAR
FISSION AN IRANIAN.
GERTRUDE ELIANE WAS A BIOCHEMIST
AND PHARMACOLOGIST TO DEVELOP
THE FIRST A MUNICIPAL S. OF DRUG
FOR ORGAN TRANSPLANTS AS WELL AS
OTHER DRUGS TREATING MALARIA AND
AIDS.
AND AUGUSTA AIDED KING KNOLL WAS
AN ENGLISH MATHEMATICIAN AND
WRITER WHO WROTE INSTRUCTIONS
FOR THE FIRST COMPUTER PROGRAM
IN THE MID EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF WOMEN AND
GIRLS AND STEM AND SUPPORT THOSE
PROGRAMS IF YOU HAVE IT HAS
SPENT EXPAND YOUR HORIZON
PROGRAM IN YOUR DISTRICT. WHERE
WOMEN AND GIRLS COME TOGETHER TO
DO SCIENCE PROJECTS IN ADVANCE
IN RESEARCH AND STEM I STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT THAT
PROGRAM AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THINK YOU?
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR ONE SIXTY SIX.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
RAMON FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD AS
A STEM SHARE I'M GLAD TO ADD MY
VOICE IN ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD. ABOUT HOW WE
MUST DO ALL THAT WE CAN CREATE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS IN THE FIELDS OF SCIENCE.
BUT WE KNOW THAT THESE
DISPARITIES HAVE EXISTED AND
IT'S WELL DOCUMENTED AND IT IS
INEXCUSABLE IT'S TIME FOR
ACTION.
OUGHT TO MAKE CHANGE
WE MUST DO A BETTER JOB OF
ENSURING THAT SCIENCE EDUCATION
AND RELATED CAREERS ARE
ACCESSIBLE. A THIS YEAR WHAT THE
END OF LAST YEAR WE STARTED WITH
OUR STAND HEARINGS.
AND WE TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTNER WITH THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS TO
LIFT UP OPPORTUNITIES FOR GIRLS
AND WOMEN. IN THE FIELDS OF STEM
I LIKE TO THANK THE COMMISSION
INTEC NET AND THE CALIFORNIA
STEM NETWORK WHO CAME FOR WITH
US.
REPORTER NUMBER OF MENTORSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE. I LIKED ALSO
THINK APPLE WHO CAME FORWARD TO
PROVIDED A WORKSHOP ON HOW TO DO
CODING FOR MANY OF THE YOUNG
WOMEN WHO CAME TO BE IN THE
WORKSHOP. ON THAT DAY THERE ARE
PROJECTIONS THAT THEY'LL BE OVER
A MILLION JOBS IN THE STEM FIELD
IN JUST A FEW YEARS AND MAYBE
ONLY HALF OF THE APPLICANTS. FOR
THOSE JOBS LET'S TAKE UP OUR
LEADERSHIP AND TAKE UP THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE OUR
TODAY'S STUDENTS TO BE THE
WORKFORCE OF TOMORROW. IN TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S EQUAL ACCESS
AND GENDER EQUALITY FOR GIRLS
AND WOMEN TO BE IN THE FIELDS OF
STAMP AND AND SCIENCE OVERALL I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. OF ACR ONE
SIXTY SIX.
THANK YOU SEE NO MORE DISCUSSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAKER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER FOR
RICHMOND AND THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE AND.
ACTUALLY US FOR AYE VOTE AND CO
AUTHORS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE FIRST RULE
FOR COFFEE MEMBERS
S. ROLES FOR COOPERS ONLY.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLL CALL IS FOR CO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES THERE ARE
SEVENTY CO AUTHORS ON THE
MEASURE. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR PLEASE
SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION PASSES.
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
I AM TEN PASS AND RETAIN ITEM
ELEVEN ACR ONE SIXTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER
KANSEN CHU AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
CELEBRATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER TEN MEMBERS I RISE SO
WAS GREAT PRIDE AND JOY. ON
BEHALF OF THE API CAUCUS
TO INTRODUCE ACR ONE SIXTY EIGHT
A LUCKY NUMBER THERE.
RECOGNIZE FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ASK OF BEGINNING
OF LUNAR NEW YEAR FOURTEEN.
FORTY SEVEN SIXTEEN.
FORTY SEVEN SIXTEEN OF AND IT IS
THE YEAR OF THE DOG.
GOOD OF AND THIS NEW YEAR IS ONE
OF THE MOST CELEBRATED.
FESTIVAL IN THE CULTURE OF
CHINESE OR. AND KOREAN.
IS TO A SICKLE FLYING SIGNIFYING
DID BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
AND AND THE OLD AGRICULTURAL
TIME THAT'S THE TIME THAT WE
RENEW OUR FRIENDSHIP AND ALSO
GETTING READY FOR A. HARVEST OF
A GOOD HARVEST YEAR.
AND THIS YEAR AS THE YEAR OF THE
DOG IN NIGHT SAYING STOOD API
CALL BECAUSE THE STAFF TO
PREPARE A COUPLE OF THE THINGS
ON YOUR DESK. FIRST ONE IS DO
DATE RAD.
ZODIAC AID THIS IS SO CHINESE
ZODIAC THE BINYAMIN SO THE ACT
HOW THE IS A LOT OF A DIFFERENT.
AND I WON'T JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE RED IS THE COLOR OF
CELEBRATION. ALSO ON YOUR DESK
WHO YOU FIND A A MANDARIN.
I DON'T KNOW MANDARIN AS AS IN
CANTONESE A MEANS GOLD AND WRONG
SHAPE SIGNIFY FAMILY UNITY. AND
ADD THAT RON THERE'S IN IS SO
PERFECT SHAPE THE FRUIT IS
USUALLY GIVEN TO PROMOTE COULD
WELL HAPPINESS AND PROSPERITY.
THE NEXT ITEM AND YOU WILL FIND
ESTHER READ THEM BELOW. UM
DESSES TRADITION FOR A MARRIED
COUPLE MARRIED PEOPLE TWO
HANDLES ENVELOPE. FILLED WITH
MONEY TO CHILDREN AND UNMARRIED
ADULT FOR GOOD LUCK.
ADD THIS SYMBOLIC MEANING IS TO
WISH VOTE GOOD FORTUNE AND WELLS
IN THE NEW YEARS TO COME.
A UNFORTUNATELY WAY YOU'LL ONLY
GET A CHOCOLATE CALLING BUT I
GUARANTEE THAT'S THAT LUCKY
CHOCOLATE COINS.
FINALLY I HAD THERE'S A FRAME
WITH THE.
NICE.
PRINT.
OF A DOG IN CELEBRATING THE
YEAR OF THE DOG AND ALSO THERE
IS SOME.
CHOCOLATE IS THOSE AND
SOMETHING SWEET I WILL HOPEFULLY
WAS TREATING YOUR MILES SINCE
RETURNED YOUR YOUR HEART AUNT.
I WAS THAT I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO WISH YOU ALL A
VERY HAPPY PROSPEROUS CHINESE
NEW YEAR. AND AMEND RING WAS SAY
GOING SHE THOUGHT HASHING OUT
HALL AND THE.
VENOMOUS WAS SAY A CHIU MONOMOY
AND I'M SURE THAT A DOCTOR CHOI
WOULD TEACH US HOW TO SAY IT. IN
THE KOREAN TECH YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER KALRA.
SPEAKER LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE. UPPER
LEADING THIS EFFORT AND.
THIS I'M SURE I'LL BE SEEING
HIM AND MANY OTHER COLLEAGUES
WITH.
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS NEXT
WEEKEND EYES.
CERTAINLY IN SAN JOSE IT'S A
VERY FESTIVE WEEKEND AND I
ALWAYS ENJOY THIS TIME OF YEAR.
EYES.
MY COLLEAGUES INDICATED IS NOT
JUST A TIME OF RENEWAL BUT AT AT
TIME. OF OF FORGIVENESS BUT IT'S
ALSO A TIME TO LOOK FORWARD TO A
NEW YEAR.
YEAR THAT WE WISH HEALTH AND
PROSPERITY AND OF IT REALLY JUST
GOOD TIDINGS ON ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND SAW A I LIKE TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO MY CONSTITUENTS. AND
TO ALL OF US CAL ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
AMONG THE MONEY. SHE NGUYEN QUAI
LA. DENG HAY FAT CHOY HAPPY NEW
YEAR TO EVERYONE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO
JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
I THIS IS A TRULY A SILVER TORY
TIME I IN ORANGE COUNTY I'VE
VERY PROUD THAT IN THE HEART OF
SEVENTY FOURTH DISTRICT THE
ORANGE COUNTY FAIRGROUNDS SO THE
UNION OF. VIETNAMESE STUDENT
ASSOCIATIONS HOUSE THERE I'VE
VERY LARGE.
TET CELEBRATION AND I KNOW WHAT
MANY OF YOU ARE WILL ALSO BE
THERE AS WELL AYE SO WITH THAT.
I'D LIKE TO JOIN US THE VARIETY
OF EASTERN CULTURES OF WHETHER
P. KOREAN CHINESE VIETNAMESE ARE
MANY MORE. HAPPY NEW YEAR HAPPY
LUNAR NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'D LIKE
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
JOSE FOR BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORD ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF ACR ONE SIXTY EIGHT. FOR MANY
CULTURES THE NEW YEAR IS MORE
THAN JUST A CELEBRATION OR A
PARTY FOR BOTH THE LUNAR IN
JEWISH NEW YEAR WHICH IS ALSO A
LUNAR CALENDAR WE EMBRACE
TRADITIONS. THAT DATE BACK TO
OUR ANCESTORS WE CONNECT WITH
OUR ROOTS IN HONOR OUR
FOREFATHERS AND MOTHERS THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR IT DATES BACK TO
THE SONG DYNASTY AS EARLY AS THE
FOURTEENTH CENTURY BEFORE THE
COMMON ERA. AND SIMILAR TO ROSH
HASHANAH THE LUNAR NEW YEAR IS
THE TIME TO SPEND WITH FAMILY
AND FRIENDS IS ALSO A HOLIDAY OF
REFLECTION.
THOSE WHO CELEBRATE FOCUS ON
MAKING AMENDS RECONCILING
DIFFERENCES AND CONNECTING WITH
PEOPLE THAT WE CARE ABOUT.
ACCORDING TO THE CHINESE TWELVE
YEAR ANIMALS O. YAK CYCLE WE ARE
NOW ENTERING INTO THE YEAR OF
THE DOG. AND WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
OF A DOG WE THINK ABOUT
FRIENDSHIP LOYALTY HAPPINESS AND
COMPATIBILITY ALL THINGS THAT WE
HEAR IN THE LEGISLATURE WORK ON
TOGETHER AS I AS WE WORK
TOGETHER ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA. I WISH EVERYONE A
HAPPY DINNER NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU I'M MADAM SPEAKER AND
THE MEMBERS HIGH RISE. IN
SUPPORT OF OUR ACR. ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THAT AS A CO AUTHOR I
COMMAND THEE  OR SO FROM US
ON WILL SAY OF FOR THIS OUR
IMPORT ON THEM RUSS SOLUTION.
NEW.
NO NO NEW YEAR AS I IMPORT ON
HOLIDAYS CELEBRATED. ARE ALL
OVER MY DISTRICT.
FROM MY VARIOUS OUR COMMUNITY
BACKGROUNDS.
TERMINOLOGY IN NO KNOW. A NEW
YEAR IS SOCK CORRECT THAT IT IS
A CELEBRATED BY. OUR MANY OUR.
AYE COUNTRIES. IN MY HERITAGE.
NO NO NEW EAR IS CORD OF SOLON.
AND SO LINE IS PSALM HOME.
HOLIDAY USED BY MANY TO RETURN
THEIR HOMETOWNS TO VISIT THEIR
RELATIVES. AND THE EXCHANGE OF
GIFTS.
MORE IMPORTANTLY. THE GOOD
TRADITION AS SUCH AS DRAWN AND
ALL OF OUR YOUNGER FAMILY
MEMBERS SO OR BORROW TO. OUR
SENIOR OUR ELDERS
AND THE GRANDPARENTS.
NOT AND THE OUT YOUR THE FEATURE
IS THAT THIS IS THE E. R.
EVERYBODY OR TRY TO. OUT WHERE A
KOREAN A TRADITION ON A DRESS.
SOMETHING IS CALLED THE HUMBLE
YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEING  ON
THE TELEVISION. I AS WE SEE THE
KOREA IS SO FULL OF WHAT
EXCITEMENT TO WORK NOW A ESTE
HOST IT WINTER ARE WILLING TAKE
GAMES. THE NEW YEAR DE. FOREST
SO RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
THAT GAME SAW HOW IT'S GONNA BE.
A CELEBRATED THE WHOLE OF THE
TRAFFIC. A WOULD SEE. NO NOT NEW
YEAR IS NOT A TIME OF
CELEBRATION I ASK FOR. OUR AYE
VOTE.
SAID THE MONEY BY THE SALE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT FIFTY ONE IT'S HOME TO
HISTORIC CHINATOWN AND LOS
ANGELES AND TO MY CONSTITUENTS.
BACK HOME I SAY XING ARE QUITE
LOW. HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR MY
FATHER HAS WORKED IN CHINATOWN
FOR MOST OF HIS ADULT LIFE AND
IN OUR COMMUNITY WE SEE. BE
CULMINATION OF THE CHINESE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY ALONG WITH
THE LATINO COMMUNITY AND HOW OUR
CULTURES HAVE COME TOGETHER TO
REALLY BE ONE FULL FORCE IN LOS
ANGELES SO. ON THIS YEAR AS WE
CELEBRATE THE YEAR OF THE DOG
PROSPERITY AND INSURING HEALTH
FOR ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY. AS CHINESE IMMIGRANT
FILIPINO IMMIGRANTS CONTINUE TO
BE A FOCUS OF ATTENTION TO OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I JUST WANNA
SAY KEEP FAITH.
HAVE FAITH. AND HOPEFULLY AS WE
CELEBRATE THIS LUNAR YEAR LUNAR
NEW YEAR WE COME TOGETHER TO
REALLY.
THINK ABOUT EVERYTHING THAT
BRINGS US TOGETHER VERSUS
EVERYTHING THAT DIVIDES US
ACROSS THIS NATION THINK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND
WOULD YOU LIKE THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS OVERTON FOR
OF FIRST OF ALL I WANNA THANK
ALL MEMBERS FOR YOUR ALL. THE
WELL WISHES AND AND THE GOOD
LUCK I LIKE YOU AM I MAKE A
LITTLE BIT CORRECTION ON MY OF
PREVIOUS PRESENTATION THEN I
WILL ASK FOR. THE FIRST ROAD TO
BE OPEN FOR A CO AUTHOR BOTH THE
CORRECTION IS KIND OF A LITTLE
AMENDMENT TO DEVELOP.
AT THEIR DUTY.
DID THOSE TWO SUITES ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDED BY THE ON THE
RE.
MEMBERS SOLVE API CAUCUS JUNE
FREEZER AND THE HE HE HE DID
THAT TO CELEBRATE THEIR
VALENTINE'S DAY SO.
I WAS THAT I WOULD. LIKE TO
COACH WILL BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHOR.
ASSUMING NOBODY WANTS TO SPEAK
ON THE CHANGE OF SWEETS.
.
THANK USE OF CLERK WILL PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOR COOPER.
MEMBERS THIS RULE IS BEING ALL
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS ROLE IS OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR PLEASE SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ITEMS TWELVE AND THIRTEEN PASS
AND RETAIN.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SAYS SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS TUESDAY FEBRUARY
THIRTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION FRIDAY FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH FLOOR SESSION AND NINE
A. M..
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASS AND RETAIN ALL MOTIONS
SHALL BE CONTINUE TO SEEING
APPEAR THERE NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MISTER
DALY SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
DOWN
ADJOURNED UNTIL FRIDAY FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH AT NINE A. M.
.
QUORUM CALLS LIFTED